welcome to Horace Horace the chana will
be discussed the latest tech news and
delve into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at the official
specs price and performance of the gtx
1180 but before we delve into that make
sure to hit that subscribe button if you
guys would like to stay updated with
latest tech news related to gaming at
pcs so as you guys already know the gtx
1180 has been anticipated for a very
long time and there are very many rumors
surrounding her right now however at
Computex mr. Jensen Hwang who is the CEO
of Nvidia stated that the next series of
GPU simon video wasn't coming out for a
very long time and this rose a lot of
concern that the next series of GPUs
from nvidia may actually not come out
till 2019
however recently gamer meld actually
made a video claiming that she was able
to get in contact with an insider from
an Adam board partner who told him that
the GTX Levin 80 is actually coming very
soon like originally anticipated now he
didn't reveal the source of his
information more than that it was an
insider from Adam board partner but
gamer Mel dusts at 52 thousand
subscribers and he has always been
accurate with his information and on top
of this he is very confident that this
news is very accurate so if he is indeed
getting his information from an Adam
board partner then this information that
he is passing is definitely legitimate
and official so what exactly did his
source tell him while starting off they
gave him a release date so when exactly
is this GTX Levendi coming out in the
first place well according to his source
there third party variant of the GTX 780
is set to launch on July 30th of this
year so Nvidia's founder Edition card
will come out on the same day if not
earlier as a result this is really good
news and we just have to wait a little
over a month for the gtx 1180
so that's great and all but how does the
performance of the gtx 1180 looked like
well gamer
Malon was also able to discover that the
gtx and lemonade he was coming with 8
gigabytes of memory just like the GTX
tent
however the gtx 1180 will most likely
have gdr six memory as opposed to the
GDR 5x memory found on the GTX 1080 so
that's what we officially know but there
are very many other leaks as well
suggesting that the performance of the
GTX at 1180 will just barely be better
than the GTX 10 atti
while all those rumors suggest is that
the gtx 1180 will have the same cuda
cores at the GTX 10 atti at 3584 CUDA
cores but at the same time it'll have
higher clock speeds with the base clock
of 1600 megahertz and a boost clock of
1800 megahertz there are even rumors
suggesting that the gtx 1180 will have a
boost clock all the way up to 4
gigahertz but i really doubt that's
going to happen because that's over a
double increase over last generation so
even if in-video was able to offer this
I doubt they would do so so I think a
much more reasonable estimate would be
1600 megahertz and 1800 megahertz like
WCF Tech originally suggested on top of
this the gtx 1180 is expected to be more
power efficient than the GTX 1080 Ti at
consuming 170 to 200 watts instead of
the 250 Watts found on the GTX 10 ATT I
along with this the gtx 1180 should also
benefit from being on the new tutoring
architecture that ole nanometer process
and G DDR six memory and it may even
have 10 so cores and ray tracing
technology which may be what DirectX 12
point 5 and 13 may be all about so as
far as performance the gtx 1180 will
just barely beat out the gtx 1080i by
about 20 frames per second so all of
this is Gretna but how much is it going
to cost well we were expecting that the
gtx 1180 was going to launch for an MSRP
of $700 just like the gtx 1080 and
according to gamer meld the third-party
variant car that he was talking with is
going to come out for an MSRP between
seven hundred and twenty dollars and
seven hundred and thirty dollars
third-party variants of graphics cards
are usually more expensive than the
founders Edition base it usually have
better cooling designs like multiple
fans and higher core clocks so based off
that I think
can safely assume that the gtx 1118
founders edition card will have an MSRP
of $700 just like the gtx 1080 and if
you look at the gtx 1080 TI while
pricing has gotten a lot better for the
gtx 980ti
you still have to spend at least seven
hundred and twenty-five dollars to get a
gtx 980ti
so at this point it doesn't really make
sense anymore to buy a gtx 980ti
considering how close two gtx 1180 is
and its performance and price you will
be spending about the same amount of
money on the gtx at 1180 as the gtx
980ti but get a good performance
increase so the gtx 11a is definitely
the way to go
unless you find a really killer deal on
the gtx 980ti like it being offered for
$600 but otherwise the gtx 1180 is the
better option when compared with the gtx
980ti
and if the gtx 1180 is indeed coming out
on July 30th like gamer Melda suggesting
then other cards like the gtx 1170 and
eleven sixty can't be far behind
so any of you guys concerned to buy a
GTX 10 series card right now I really
recommend that you guys just wait a
little bit longer and get eleven series
card because for the same price you can
get a lot more performance so as a
result even if the 10 series cards hit
MSRP or even if you find a really good
deal on them I suggest that you guys
wait for the 1100 series card and get
one of those but that's all I got for
you guys this time so how do you guys
feel about this are you guys excited the
gtx 1180 is coming so soon or did you
just buy a gtx 1080 and you're currently
vigorously reading through the return
policy for Newegg make sure to comment
down below what you guys think about
this because I do read all my comments
I'm curious as to what you guys think -
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time fine
[Music]